[Musique]
depuis trois ans le département a
instauré une nouvelle dynamique
partenariale avec les communes à travers
la mise en place du pacte de solidarité
territoriale le PST ce jeudi 10 novembre
le président Cyril Melchior était en
visite à Saint-Benoît où il a fait le
point sur la mise en œuvre du PST sur le
territoire de la commune et sur les
prochains projets aux côtés du maire
Patrice Selly c'est l'occasion pour moi
quand je me rends dans une commune de
voir l'état d'avancement aussi bien des
travaux que des actions sociales et
aujourd'hui à Saint-Benoît je suis
heureux de constater que le maire son
équipe en lien bien sûr avec les
conseillé départementaux et bien nous
travaillons à mettre ce test de en place
nous avons une grande souplesse dans
l'utilisation donc de ce PST ce qui veut
dire que parfois nous devons redéployer
les crédits en investissement au
fonctionnement il s'agit pour nous
d'accompagner sur l'action sociale des
petites garçons en fait au bénéfice de
nos concitoyens et nous faisons aussi
donc des travaux de financement des
travaux au bénéfice de la mairie et pour
toutes ces actions et bien nous avons
besoin du co-financement du département
parce que au vu de la situation
contrainte budgétairement de la commune
nous n'avons pas la capacité et bien de
contribuer davantage au budget de notre
CCAS et l'occasion était donnée ce matin
de remercier personnellement monsieur le
Président malikor de sa contribution à
travers le PST2 dans le cadre du PST une
enveloppe de 410000 euros avait été
consacré pour le volet fonctionnement au
Centre Communal d'Action Sociale
bénédictins qui a notamment donné lieu
au financement d'une aide au permis de
conduire pour les jeunes de la commune
visant à favoriser leur insertion
professionnelle
de pouvoir passer le PMI pour les jeunes
en difficulté parfois seulement
accessibles pour tout le monde je
remercie le département et le CC de
m'avoir dit cette aide car je suis en ce
moment sur un concours de gendarmerie et
ben pour le transport c'est pas facile
le but c'est tout mais c'est pas
vraiment passé et tout donc à
l'obscension de mon permis j'espère que
pouvoir avoir ma covoiture pour le
déplacement pour aller vers les
pharmacies de nuit Warriors dans le
cadre du PST2 la commune de Saint-Benoît
a travers son CCAS lance un dispositif
d'aide financière pour la téléassistance
qui vise à favoriser le maintien à
domicile des personnes âgées ou en
situation de handicap
enfin les deux aiguilles se sont dirigés
vers l'espace naturel sensible de Sainte
Marguerite le site abrite une pépinière
de production de plantes indigènes qui a
été agrandi en 2022 en soutien au plan
un million d'arbres le projet
d'aménagement et de valorisation du site
de Sainte Marguerite a été présenté par
les services du département ainsi que le
projet pro deo qui vise à améliorer les
conditions en eau dans les hauts
[Musique]